ودمنا المجموعه الخامسه حقق فريق مانشستر
يونايتد فوزا صعبه نعلي مضيفه ريال
سوسيداد الاسباني بهدف نظيف هذا الهدف جاء
عن طريق اللاعب الارجنتيني اليخاندرو
جرناشو في الدقيقه سريعه 10 وفشل
اليونايتد في تصدر المجموعه الخامسه رغم
الفوز حيث يتساوى مع ريال سوسيداد برصيد
خمسه 10 نقطه ولكن يتفوقوا الفريق
الاسباني بفارق الاهداف
الافريقي
انهم رجال رائعون قاموا بكل شيء من اجل
ايقاع قوي للمباراه
بفوزهم بهدف لصفر
اهنئهم على هذا الفوز نحن في مانشستر
يونايتد دائما نشعر بخيبه
وكان لدينا ايضا شيء جميل
انه يجب علينا ان نعمل اكثر جديه لتسجيل
المزيد من الاهداف واعتقد انه ضمنا هذه
المجموعه اطيحت لنا فرصا عديده للحصول على
فريق اهداف افضل هذا هو تحليل الصحيح
[موسيقى]
في بعض المباريات الاخرى فاز فريق ارسنال
على زوريخ بهد
ف النتيجه